this is the annual welcome Ramadan
exhibition in misrata it showcases local
products like dates olive oil and honey
and all at discounted rates
Anwar musa's company has been coming
here for the last two years but he says
business isn't great
Russia's exhibit was much better than
this year this year it's just been okay
yesterday was really slow it's a bit
better today
this is what's known as the Ramadan Rush
people storm markets to stock up on food
items ahead of time
it's the holiest month in the Islamic
calendar Muslims around the world will
Fast from sunrise to sunset families
spend time together breaking their fasts
but for some Ramadan will be difficult
this year
lives in Ebu grain about a hundred
kilometers east of misrata
his family of eight is struggling to
make ends meet
my salary is very low it's about 100 a
month it is not enough to provide for my
family I come to miss writer because
basic Goods like flour tomato based and
oil are cheaper here with the rise in
prices many families are struggling in
Ramadan
is a professor of Economics at a local
University he says when a central bank
devalued the Libyan dinar in 2021
people's salaries stayed the same
Libya Imports all of his products with
the dollar so the problem is people's
salary are very weak compared to the
dollar most people make around 250 to
300 a month which means they are under
the poverty line Libya has been riddled
with conflict and political divisions
for over a decade the UN says an
estimated 1.3 million people are in need
of humanitarian assistance in the
country
Libya has Africa's largest oiled crude
reserves and should be a prosperous
country people here hope its instability
can be overcome so their financial
burdens lighten Malik trainer Al Jazeera
misrata